en france un titulaire du permis de
conduire sur deux est une femme
d'ailleurs monsieur vous vous en rendez
compte
[Musique]
la femme qui conduit est pleinement
consciente de son égalité avec le sexe
fort référendum à présent au niveau le
plus piquant
monsieur est ce que vous prêtez votre
voiture à votre femme jamais pourquoi
parce qu elle abîmerait puisque à l'abri
à la une et c'est une voiture c'est un
objet très personnel est-ce vous qui
avez choisi votre voiture et vous en
êtes contente très vous l'a prêté à
votre mari jamais jamais pourquoi parce
que j'aime pas trop c'est une voiture
alors si on sort le soir on prend
souvent la petite c'est plus facile à
garer mais c'est moi qui conduis
sachez tout de même qu'il vous reste
encore des possibilités d'expression
dans les choix mais qui s'orientent -
vers la technique que vers l'esthétique
c'est elle je crois qu'il choisit la
couleur qui choisit la couleur
intérieure et c'est elle je prends
d'ailleurs cassis pour avoir la radio
pourra parler katché ça je suis sûr
qu'il ya beaucoup
influence féminine dans l'achat des voix
la question existe-t-il réellement des
voitures faites pour vous mesdames
[Musique]
le seul ennui c'est que je crois que
voit-il typiquement féminines ont
malheureusement des mois super moteur à
injection suspension soupapes chevaux
fiscaux rodage connais pas ce n'est pas
moi qu'ils l'affirment c'est vous
mesdames votre préoccupation essentielle
la mode de demain
[Musique]
je suis sûr et certain c'est
l'automobile qui a une influence sur la
mode parce que notre temps dans la vie
moderne ne peut plus dissocier les
automobiles de la vie de même qu'on peut
plus dissocier le téléphone de la vie
moi je sais qu'au début a je me suis dit
le pantalon non c'est pas féminin c'est
pas très beau il faut être très très mal
il faut très grande pour pouvoir le
porter et maintenant je suis arrivé au
point que j'ai chante sur scène en
pantalon sécurité connaît pas non plus
notre enquête le prouve les pédales ne
sont pas adaptés à vos besoins
un conseil en attendant de meilleurs
pénale munissez-vous de talons plats
pour conduire
[Musique]
sondage masculin mesdames vous avez
mauvaise réputation volant et vous
prétendez souvent le contraire
enrica est-ce que vous conduisez je
conduis très peu j'ai mon permis depuis
huit ans déjà
mais comme j'ai trouvé que j'étais
distrait au volant
je pensais que je ferai une un grand
service je rendrai à moi même et à mes
concitoyens si je conduirai pas et je
trouve qu'il y aura pas mal des gens qui
auraient mieux fait de faire exactement
comme moi la femme confond souvent la
droite de la gauche
les prudentes mais les statistiques
l'attestent elles sont de grandes froid
ce dell et les paquets bas parlons-en
vous embarrasser nos voitures nul
n'échappe à la société de consommation
et ses problèmes quotidiens
vous consommez beaucoup et bien entendu
le fait du déchet ou plutôt vous
entretenez un savant désordre
mais comment vous en tenir rigueur sur
le plan féminine moi je trouve qu'il
faut avoir plein de petits endroits des
rangements dans une voiture sino une
voiture devient très vite un foutoir
je crois qu'on dit comme ça c'est si
désagréable pour le propriétaire de la
voiture car chaque fois quand ils
rentrent ils disent il a trop arranger
finalement orange rien
exigeante vous l'être plus encore
lorsque certaines d'entre vous rêvent de
transformer la voiture en kitchenette
voire même en salon de beauté
et si vous maquillez vous avez besoin
d'une poubelle la voiture a voilà non
pratiquants j'entends je vois quelqu'un
qui comprend les problèmes de la femme
en effet il faut avoir même un petit est
une petite boîte des déchets quelque
chose en plastique qui on peut laver
qu'on peut accrocher quelque part et
qu'on peut jeter tout ce qu'il faut dans
la voiture et puis une fois que l'on a
terminé se maquiller jeter dehors et
certaines d'entre vous rêvent
d'accessoires pour le moins curieux moi
j'aimerais bien avoir par exemple une
prise pour un séchoir à cheveux
électriques
quand on est au bord de la mer contre
baigne et qu'on doit repartir
immédiatement pour une soirée où
quelqu'un faute d'avoir assez choix nous
risquons
et le sac
tantôt posé sur le siège où ils tondent
ou accroché au rétroviseur il gêne vous
réclamez un crochet qui peut se fixer
autre part que n'importe où vous pouvez
l'acheter mais ce crochet est un des
rares accessoires existants il y a le
chauffe biberons les gants ensuite les
lunettes de soleil
l'accoudoir vide poches ou vite sac et
c'est tout il me reste à vous dire que
quel que soit votre style ou votre mode
de vie
le résultat impartial de notre enquête
est le suivant les voitures sont un peu
trop pensé par les hommes pour les
hommes
messieurs les constructeurs vous qui
passez des heures à cogiter sur la forme
d'un cap ou l'agressivité d'un
pneumatique penser à ces femmes qui ont
un besoin parmi tant d'autres se sentir
des femmes dans leur voiture c'est
peut-être de ce côté que se dessine
l'avenir
[Musique]